[Música]
hola bienvenidos a france 24 nuestro
invitado de hoy es clau de juan el
entrenador apodado el grupo rubio el
brujo rubio es de hecho el título de su
libro publicado hace poco por ediciones
harto gracias por estar en nuestro plato
y plato
de profesión este tuvo una carrera
profesional solo en francia luego se
convirtió en una especie de ave
migratoria en asia pero sobre todo en
áfrica al frente de muchas elecciones
concretamente seis selecciones africanas
19 fases finales de la copa africana de
naciones
ahora estamos en plena edición 2022 de
esta competición que se celebra en
camerún plan de fusión y en camerún
además bueno si es un país que ganó la
can en
1988 la pregunta que se hacen todos los
hinchas africanos pero sobre todo los
campeones es es en su opinión camerún
tiene posibilidades reales en llegar
hasta el final de liu
si entraron bien en la competencia con
solidez no de forma brillante pero si
sólidas bastante eficaz y sabemos que es
difícil de nahr en camerún
lastimosamente para ellos ocurrió la
primera vez que organizaron la copa
africana de naciones en 1972 de andy o
el congo los derrotó en casa en las
semifinales final papal cuba a difícil
pero creo que todavía necesitan mucho
trabajo en el ámbito colectivo aunque
hay que decir que el señor infantino al
haber permitido que los jugadores
llegaran sólo unos días sin fondo y
aunque hoy raudo el presidente de la
fifa sólo unos días antes del torneo
algo que es absolutamente inconcebible
es decir que los entrenadores no
tuvieron ningún tiempo para prepararse y
que los primeros partidos se utilizaron
finalmente como partidos de
entrenamiento y de preparación ya que no
hubo ninguna fase preparatoria como
suele pasar en la copa africana de
naciones porque hubo mucha presión para
no celebrar esta carta
félix infantino hizo todo lo posible
para que no lo fuera por eso digo que
fue realmente el ska ping de áfrica
el día de la inauguración de la carne
estuvo presente y fue abucheado y con
razón hizo todo lo posible para que la
copa africana de naciones no se
celebrará en el continente africano le
habría gustado tal vez que ciertos
eventos se hicieran en los países del
golf que es es desde el desprecio e
indiferencia o es que se obedece a los
intereses de los clubes en los que
no lo soporto porque lo he visto varias
veces me he reunido con él varias veces
cuando ha ido a áfrica y nunca habla de
fútbol solo habla de dinero y no tiene
la impresión de que trabaja para el
fondo monetario internacional que se
pavonea de capital en capital y que
piensa que puede aprovecharse de la
codicia de los líderes americanos
algunos son codiciosos efectivamente
podría funcionar pero a la larga saldrá
perdiendo sólo una nota de mis materno
pero a áfrica hizo bien en insistir
claro claro algo que volviendo al
terreno de juego hay otro equipo que
usted entreno que nunca ha ganado la
copa africana y del que se habla como
uno de los favoritos senegal la primera
ronda fue muy difícil pero están aquí
a eso
es muy ambiguo es complicado para mí
porque apoyo a dos países efectivamente
son camerún y senegal porque les debo
mucho pienso que gané con camerún
debería haber ganado esa copa africana
con senegal yo creo que eso habría roto
el techo de cristal que llevan décadas
intentando romper porque deberíamos
haberla ganado en 1990 o 1992
creo que tenía la mejor plantilla las
deficiencias de juego pequeñas cosas
hicieron que cada vez llegáramos solo
hasta las semifinales y a los cuartos de
final así que eso influye mucho hay un
bloqueo psicológico entre los
senegaleses con las compañías locales
psicológicos de senegal
sigue existiendo y destruyó la y es
donde más siguen existiendo tuvieron un
arranque difícil y tiene un equipo ni
siquiera un equipo una plantilla
extraordinaria pero creo que cuanto más
avance el torneo más los veremos emerger
al más alto nivel tuvieron algunos
problemas con el commit conway que iba y
venía con el watford y el olympique de
marsella cuéllar dejó el equipo volvió y
así no fue fácil para ellos empezar la
copa africana
y hay una particularidad en esta copa
africana de naciones y es que dos
tercios de los entrenadores si contenía
el 16 de los 24 son africanos ciudadanos
africanos marca esto un cambio porque a
menudo hemos visto en el banquillo y
usted es uno de ellos obviamente a
entrenadores occidentales especialmente
europeos
me da un poco de miedo este argumento
porque creó una especie de división de
los entrenadores africanos que es un
entrenador africano son mis amigos llamé
el vell marí y al jones hice los
entrenadores de argelia senegal dos de
los tres grandes favoritos de esta
competencia más africanos que yo que he
pasado más tiempo que ellos en el
continente africano nacieron en francia
hicieron su carrera profesional que en
francia que obtuvieron sus diplomas en
francia es cierto que uno es argelino de
origen y otro senegalés así que siempre
desconfió un poco de estas divisiones a
veces un poco demagógicas que se hacen
para decir áfrica para los africanos
hablo de eso con más propiedad porque
mis asistentes locales verdaderamente
locales se convirtieron en entrenadores
después de haber trabajado conmigo que
es decir allí donde he estado he formado
a entrenadores nacionales que se han
hecho cargo de equipos nacionales por lo
tanto creo que debemos tener cuidado de
no entrar en ese tipo de división es
bueno que por ejemplo admira a tu
entrenador de las comoras que hizo toda
su carrera en francia que incluso fue
entrenador de un club amateur en francia
se haya hecho cargo de la selección de
las comoras porque hace un trabajo
extraordinario es un gran logro por
cierto
claro terminaron por delante de ghana
imagínense las comoras conozco mejor a
este equipo porque es el que nos sacó
con todo de la clasificación para la
copa africana de naciones
dije que era un equipo al que había que
respetar que no era un equipo de segunda
al que le reprocha vamos después de que
nos hubiera derrotado efectivamente
deberíamos haber ganado pero son un
equipo de calidad e hicieron un buen
trabajo podrían haber estado ya
clasificados si no hubiera sido por un
gol en el último minuto del segundo
partido así que hay muchas cosas que van
bien creo que lo importante sea cual sea
nacionalidad es que la gente viva y
trabaje en áfrica
cristo voy a volver a la historia que
usted cuenta en este libro a mediados de
los años 80 dejó de ser entrenador del
grenoble y se convirtió en entrenador de
camerún así que le pusieron una trampa
en la scj el doctor jean pierre se
propuso para las ópticas y me empujó un
poco a salir el multimillonario
presidente de la época marc de jong que
quería multar a uno de mis jugadores
porque habíamos empatado y yo me negué
entonces inmediatamente se cree una
división y se me pidió que me fuera y
luego por casualidad gracias al berbatov
que vivía en grenoble y fue un poco mi
maestro y auge me juliá que había sido
embajador en españa e inglaterra que era
un antiguo jugador de 'la berbatov en el
sant y tiempo y no lograba jugar en
camerún fue mi esposa la que le
respondió y él le dijo a camerún le
gusta tener a clouds camerún no quería
en realidad pero era que él le había
preguntado a albert bato por el perfil
albert vactor le había dicho creo que el
perfil ideal para un país como camerún
es un entrenador joven como claude dijo
que ya dónde era la capital más bonita
del mundo que era una pequeña parís -
embotellamientos que no había casas en
parís pero que encontraríamos en gander
eso no correspondía del todo a la
realidad llegué a camerún y
efectivamente aunque no habíamos hablado
nada en absoluto con el ministro que era
el entonces sultán que acababa de
fallecer
ibrahim en bombo en joya una persona
maravillosa también estaba el director
de deportes del ministerio quien anunció
ante un centenar de periodistas en las
de conferencias que yo era un nuevo
entrenador para un gran disgusto de mi
esposa quien no estaba al tanto igual
que yo que ella sintió que la había
traicionado al aceptar el puesto sin
habérselo dicho y el ministro después de
esta conferencia me dijo con su voz
gruesa mire entrenador tuve que decir
eso porque estábamos en una mala
situación acababan de perder 4-1 en
zambia habían quedado por fuera del
mundial era complicado así que terminé
como entrenador sin haber discutido los
términos de un contrato algo de lo que
nunca me ha arrepentido
[Música]
luego pasó por muchas peripecias fue
contratado por el entonces presidente de
la república democrática del congo
joseph kabila y fue a contratarlo el
mismo y está le mimen tuvo que revelar
si le pidió a su embajador de la
república democrática del congo en parís
que se pusiera en contacto conmigo de
hecho fue la embajada de túnez para
celebrar el título de túnez en la copa
africana de naciones
el embajador vino a verme y me dijo al
presidente le gustaría absolutamente que
dirigiera al equipo de la rdc
el mismo quien me dice volver a la rdc
por segunda vez la primera vez nos fue
muy bien pero después los contactos pues
es mucho más complicado
políticos desempeñaron un papel directo
a veces demasiado de odio si por eso es
un poco mentira cuando la fifa dice que
sólo es el poder del fútbol y no de los
políticos pero cuando infantil nos llega
a un país que pide sólo pide una cosa
reunirse con el jefe de estado no con el
presidente de la federación así que los
políticos juegan un papel porque porque
salvo algunas federaciones privilegiadas
los demás no tienen los medios
económicos para alquilar un avión para
que el equipo pueda viajar en buenas
condiciones para reservar hoteles para
parar los billetes de avión de los
jugadores expatriados que vienen a jugar
con la selección las federaciones no
tienen los medios así que obviamente es
el gobierno el que está detrás también
ha conocido algunos grandes jugadores
como george way entonces llegó a ser
presidente de liberia a usted desempeñó
un papel clave en su contratación por el
a ese mónaco que impuso su carrera
interna se muere todo estamos hablando
de los líderes paso de futbolista a ex
futbolista a presidente de la federación
camerunesa qué suerte pero también qué
riesgo qué riesgos y es un gran riesgo
pero qué suerte porque el menos sabemos
que él no va a dedicarse a calcular
cuántas mansiones podrá construir
durante su mandato sino que se centrará
completamente en el desarrollo del club
del en camerún de raid completo soccer
is the short
los dolores o le dije que se centrará en
la formación de las personas en la
formación de los educadores o en la
calidad de los campos de entrenamiento
en el equipo de entrenamiento en cosas
simples por ejemplo la red de protección
detrás de la portabilidad hace que las
didácticas de penalty sean más
eficientes pues el balón no termina en
un campo de caña y no se pierde tiempo
en ir a buscarlo
así que hay que ir hacia la eficiencia
luego empezar a pensar en el áfrica
subshariana crear campeonatos
profesionales pero africanos con
realidades africanas con una metodología
africana no se trata de copiar lo que se
hace en europa o en sudamérica o en asia
hay formas de adaptar el fútbol
profesional en áfrica que eso evitaría
que cientos de niños arriesguen sus
vidas en barrios en camiones
sobrecargados para aplicar a lo que
ellos creen que es el dorado que es
europa que a menudo está muy lejos de
ser el dorado en equipos o el dorado que
los golpes que sube pero desde luego
clot lengua muchas gracias muchas
anécdotas para los aficionados en la
historia del fútbol en áfrica
en otros lugares están en el brujo rubio
publicado en francés por ediciones alto
gracias gracias y gracias a ustedes por
haber visto esta entrevista en nuestro
canal
[Música]